[Music]
alright alright hi should we start with
my face I always look like this and I
look really happy all the time I am well
aware that I look just ecstatic
constantly and I don't feel like this I
really don't I feel I feel okay I feel
fine
and I look crazy happy I don't I don't
even buy it really I I wake up in the
morning and I look in the mirror and I
go that is inaccurate I don't know what
you want me to do I just walk around
people go look at that chip or fella and
I go I'm okay I feel like I look more
like a comedy club logo than I do a
comedian like oh yeah I could be a sign
in 1953 that's the kind of life I could
sell ice cream in the 50s
I can't go places I can't just show up
at a funeral you know I guess I'm so
sorry for your loss
I uh I can't ask a girl out you know
what are you doing tomorrow it's just so
creepy isn't it I'm single and I'm
trying not to be single which sounds
desperate really you shouldn't you
shouldn't say that out loud
it's true but there's no woman in
earshot of that statement going that's
the one dibs on that
smiley desperate fella but it's really I
mean part of your single life is great
you've got all this freedom you can do
whatever you want whenever you want
right
maybe someone wanders into your life
maybe not you don't care it's just it's
a great place to be I'm not there
anymore
I mean freedom is amazing but I'm not
popping up alone in bed in the middle of
the night going I can do whatever I want
you know we're not rolling around in bed
on look at the freedom
I'm not brave Harding in bed at 3:00 I
am you understand I'm not watching
infomercials and eating a Lean Cuisine
because I'm living life in my terms
ah you're the only people I've talked to
today no I'm not very good socially this
is all I do I just do this and go home
and think of things to tell strangers
tomorrow I don't drink I think that's
part of it it's it's tough to be social
when you don't drink because you don't
want me around you know like some nights
it's fine but many nights I get this
feeling back from the group like we all
got together and we realized you're
going to remember most of this so we'd
like for you to go home now what you
don't think about is it goes both ways
you're drinking affects my life do you
ever nobody ever thinks about that but
it's true because I'm a good listener
you know so I listen and I listen and I
listen I'm fine with that really I'm
okay with that what I'm not okay with is
the next day when I end up alone in a
park waiting for a picnic
there is no picnic it's just I'm just
alone on a blanket with baby carrots and
cheese cubes waiting for someone with a
five digit phone number to try and call
now you don't get that kind of detail in
a joke unless you've actually lived
[Applause]